ما نحاول تطويره باستخدام البكسل
3 هو الهاتف الذكي الأكثر فائدة
في السوق الذي نريد صنعه حتى
نساعد المستخدمين حقًا في إنجاز الأشياء التي
يرغبون في إنجازها ويمكننا
القيام بذلك بشكل فريد بسبب أصولنا
وبرامج الذكاء الاصطناعي.  والأجهزة ، ومن
الأمثلة على ذلك تقنية شاشة الاتصال الخاصة بنا ،
حيث يمكن لشخص قد
لا ترغب في التحدث معك أن مكالمة غير مرغوب فيها
يمكنه الاتصال بهاتفك ويمكننا الرد
عليه لأنك تقول سبب اتصالك
تم اختيارك لـ  عطلة مجانية
لا يمكنهم التحدث الآن ولكن حاول الاتصال
بهم لاحقًا
شكرًا وداعًا ، هل
لديك نوع جديد مفضل من ميزة الكاميرا المستوحاة من الذكاء الاصطناعي
، أنا بالتأكيد معجب كبير
بكابينة الصور لأنها تلتقط
الصورة تلقائيًا نيابة عنك  وهو يجعل
من السهل جدًا التقاط صورة ذاتية ، فنحن
نبدو رائعين ، وما تبحث عنه
هو أنها تبحث فقط عن الابتسامات ، فهي
تبحث عن الابتسامات ، وتبحث عن
الإضاءة وتبحث عن مكان
تركيز عينيك
[موسيقى]